Let's go next to our caller from the two 62
area code.
Who's calling today from two six two
[inaudible]
Hey, is that me?
Yes it is.
Hello.
Oh, hi David.
Uh, I'm Matthew and from Milwaukee.
Hey Matthew.
All right, it's great to talk to you.
So you recently did a segment about how the
Democrats might have a chance of getting to
the Senate, right?
Yes.
All right.
So I noticed in that you never talked about
possibly getting rid of Mitch McConnell.
Um, but you have talked about that race before.
Do you think that we have a chance in Kentucky?
I mean, it's a big uphill battle there.
The reason I didn't include it is it's, it
is a long shot and I get that Amy McGrath
is raising some good money, but if I'm, you
know, I want to push that as much as I can
to try to get McConnell out.
But at the same time if I'm going to do a
serious analysis of like the five seats that
are most likely to be taken back [inaudible]
or even the seven seats most likely to be
taken back.
Mitch McConnell's seed is not one of those
five or seven.
All right.
That's too bad.
Yeah, it is sad.
Okay.
That's really all I had to ask.
All right, Matthew from Milwaukee, appreciate
the phone call.
Thank you.
Oh sorry.
Yes.
Okay.
Now he's gone.
Alright.
That's it for calls today.
It has been a very, very rough day with the
phone, with the call system.
Something.
Something is very, there's must be something
going on with the a, we've got like gremlins
in the system or something like that.
I think I've got the wrong type of wire
or to connected, so we will try to deal with
that for next week.
That's it for today.
Quick break audience questions coming up next